[Music]
for this scene in coco pixar's computer
kept getting mama imelda's skirt caught
between her skeleton joints
so pixar developed a whole new
simulation system
and digitally wrapped every joint with a
layer of invisible fabric
every single pixar movie has pushed the
boundaries of 3d animation with detailed
work like this
from lighting food with two light
sources to simulating realistic fur
let's pick up where we left off in part
one with merida's realistic looking
locks in brave
merida had a lot of hair if you unwound
a strand of it it would measure
four feet in length but the simulation
tech hadn't yet tackled the unique
physics of curly hair where each curl
has a spring-like structure
but the overall movement of the hair is
light and soft in a way that seems to
defy gravity
pixar's first step was to build merida's
hair in layers
each with a different tightness of curl
to get that natural looking variation
the team then spent three years
developing a special simulator called
taz
that'd be powerful enough to handle the
1500 hand-placed curls on merida's head
taz accounted for all the interactions
between different strands while making
sure that every curl held its shape
the system also changed the effect of
gravity on merida's hair
using a gravity coefficient closer to
the one on the moon
than the one on earth with a lower
gravity the hair could keep its mass but
flow and bounce in a natural way
to give the hair its softness the
lighting team used a mix of subsurface
scattering
and colored shadows to imitate the
complex way curly hair scatters and
transmits light
it took two months just to nail the hair
in this scene when merida pulls back her
hood to reveal the full
volume of curls with that work set the
stage for pixar to represent
all hair textures on screen in the
future
in cars pixar used ray tracing in small
doses to create reflections and shadows
in dynamic scenes with
lots of shiny vehicles but for the vast
majority of shots
pixar's artists still built reflections
and mapped out shadows by hand
that changed with monsters university
the lighting team wanted more time to
focus
on the artistic rather than the
engineering side of lighting
like creating new scare lights for scary
monster scenes
to streamline the process the goal was
to retrace pretty much
everything all the shadows and light
refractions even the reflections in a
character's eye
this required an overhaul of the
lighting system the studio had used
since the first toy story
pixar built a new system called global
illumination
that modeled the natural distribution of
light in a scene all based on real world
physics
now every time an artist placed a light
source in a shot the computer would know
how that light would travel and interact
with other elements
and it would stimulate the resulting
bright spots shadows and reflections
global illumination became the default
lighting system for
every pixar movie making pixar's light
more closely resemble the kind we see in
real life
but this model didn't account for more
fantastical scenarios
like we'd see and inside out
joy the main character of inside out is
supposed to resemble a star
she's made up of glowing particles that
radiate off her skin
this character had to shed warm yellow
blue light wherever she appeared in a
scene
and the light had to track with her
bouncy movement which wasn't easy
since she's literally a ball of energy
so pixar's renderman team came up with
an effect they called geometric aerial
lights or geolight
this tool allowed lighting artists to
select a character model and turn it
into a mobile light source
that way joy's light could travel with
her if she walks up to a prop
she projects her glow on it and she
casts light onto other characters too
like this pivotal scene with sadness
her light was also accurate to her body
structure for example when she picks
something up we see the light emanate
through her fingers
this made the outward glow look more
believable taking pixar's lighting
system yet another step forward
nature plays a bigger role in the good
dinosaur than in any other pixar film
so the filmmakers really needed to nail
the landscape of the american northwest
they were especially focused on the huge
constantly changing clouds they observed
on a research trip
traditionally pixar movies used matte
painted clouds meaning the artist would
paint clouds onto background plates
but the good dinosaur took place
entirely outside
with clouds and almost every scene so
they decided for the first time to
create entirely
volumetric clouds that meant these
clouds were 3d
objects animators could move around like
a character or a key set piece
but unlike a character or set a
volumetric object has no defined surface
it's just made up of billions of tiny
particles the clouds team built a huge
library of what they called cloud
lego parts they joined these volumetric
forms together to create huge clouds of
every type
rain clouds stratus clouds and cumulus
clouds with the clouds actually in the
scene
viewers can move in and around the 3d
forms as the camera moves making this
world
that much more immersive
hank from finding dory was probably the
hardest thing
pixar had ever animated at that point
according to michael stalker
a supervising animator on the film he
definitely wouldn't have been possible
in finding nemo
most four or two-legged characters like
humans have joints and defined limits to
their movement but
octopi don't have skeletons or any clear
structure to how they move
to capture that extreme flexibility
pixar had to rethink its whole approach
to character construction
this started with hank's rig the basic
puppet that animators use to control the
character's movement
while humans have clearly defined elbows
that bend hank's elbow had to travel
down the length of his tentacle so
pixar's engineers developed a special
rig that used a cylinder as hank's elbow
and relied on a special curve function
to dictate how that muscle should move
this let animators stay faithful to that
key rolling motion of octopus tentacles
the filmmakers also needed the webbing
between hank's tentacles to flatten and
spread out with each movement
so the character team created a new
control to set the depth of the webbing
this helped give hank the squishy
squashy motion that you see here and it
allowed pixar to give life to its most
complex character to date
the filmmakers behind the third cars
movie wanted to emphasize the aging
details on hero characters like the
older racer louise nash
any car's surface is composed of
multiple layers metal flake paint with a
clear coating
car stickers dirt grime and mud
composited on top
but traditionally when pixar showed an
object with detailed texture from a more
distant shot
all the little details would merge into
a single pixel making the object's
surface look too
smooth so pixar developed a technology
called bump roughness mapping which
converts what looks like
bumps up close into surface roughness
and farther away shots
louise for example keeps the texture of
her clear coat scratches even in medium
and wide shots and this tech wasn't only
applicable to cars
pixar could use the bump roughness
method to preserve details on all kinds
of 3d objects as we'll see for
incredibles 2.
clothing simulation was always going to
be a big undertaking in coco
the movie demanded more cloth than any
other pixar feature and many scenes
would involve
a lot of movement on top of this the
characters weren't just humans but
skeletons phones have all these crevices
where clothes can bunch up and collide
with each other
creating too many collisions for pixar
simulator fizz-t to handle
so the studio spent three years creating
a new continuous collision detection
program
which helped the computer automatically
resolve issues like cloth bunching up
around a skeleton's hand or snagging on
a bony knee
animators also digitally wrap the
skeleton's joints with super stretchy
invisible material
so that when the bone separated the
pants would touch that invisible barrier
and not fall into the gaps
this was a creative solution to a unique
problem but it laid the groundwork for
even more advanced cloth simulation
later on
fashion was also a big part of the
incredibles but in the first
movie the character's suits weren't
actual clothing they were patterns
shaded onto the character's bodies which
is why in some shots the fabric behaves
more like skin
and the incredibles logo stretches out
in unrealistic ways
for the second movie the filmmakers
wanted their clothing to work better
with the extreme movements of characters
like elastigirl
that began with constructing actual
digital garments that sat on top of the
character's skin
like normal clothing the next key step
was manipulating uv
coordinates on the clothes in
incredibles 2 a tech called 3d uv
scaling preserved the details of a cloth
when stretched or compressed
pixar also found a way to use bump
roughness mapping the technology from
cars 3 to keep very fine illuminated
details intact
even when elastigirl extended her body
to wild proportions
that made it possible for elastigirl to
get a brand new suit
this iridescent unitard that keeps its
subtle shimmery texture through
all the hyper-flexible movements compare
that to this shot of elastigirl
stretching out in the first incredibles
the surface of her new suit looks much
more like actual fabric
you can see how pixar has stretched the
limits of what its cloth technology can
do
the fourth toy story brought up issues
of scale thanks to all the scenes set in
the antique store and thus
all the toys there were over 10 000
antiques in the store and pixar had to
find a way to program
each and every one with varying levels
of wear and tear
animators tackled this challenge by
assigning three different ages to the
antiques
fairly new moderately aged and extremely
aged
the computer then gave the items surface
details that fit those ages
from micro scratches on china platters
to wear and tear on
old rugs the ability to add detail to so
many different objects is what gave the
world of toy story 4
its visual complexity and appeal
pixar's had its share of unique
characters but dad from onward
is made up of only a pair of legs the
rest of his body is just
stuffing with a sweatshirt vest and
gloves thrown over it which made it
difficult to animate
dad's legs could be rigged and animated
like a traditional character
using reference footage filmed in front
of a green screen but his upper half had
no
skin or structure underneath it so it
called for simulation
not animation in many shots the arms for
example
just had to flop around a movement
that's more believable when simulated so
the filmmakers developed a hybrid
simulation animation rig for dad
with this rig animators could manipulate
dad's lower half like they usually would
but the simulation team controlled
everything above the belt when needed
the movement of dad's stuffing was based
on a volumetric sim
a simulation for something with volume
while the clothes on top of the stuffing
were largely controlled with standard
cloth simulation
pixar also improved the interaction
between volumetric sims and cloth sims
so that if you pushed on dad's clothing
the stuffing would get squished
believably and vice versa if you pushed
on the stuffing the clothing would move
out of the way
the hybrid rig improved the relationship
between separate simulations
and ultimately it showed how simulation
and animation could join forces to
create realistic movement on an
unrealistic character
pixar needed to make its musician
characters play instruments
most notably joe who had to go through
the complicated rapid motions of playing
the piano
at first the team tried to use
simulation to handle the interactions
between joe's fingers and the keys
relying on a collision system
like the one used for the cloth in coco
but the collision system didn't work
because joe's fingers were too heavy for
the computer's piano keys
so instead of simulating the movement
character technical director jason
davies developed what he called
a finger contact rig when one of joe's
fingers pushed down on a key the rig
would calculate the correct angle for
the key to rotate so it looked like joe
was pushing it
the modeling and rigging teams also gave
joe's hand 292 controls
including variables they had never used
before even adding a control for each
tendon to convey the tension in joe's
hand as he played
this level of hand and wrist control
made his performances look
passionate and convincing on screen with
a level of realism that pushed the
boundaries of human movement and
animation
luca is a coming-of-age story about a
sea monster who can transform
into a human and the filmmakers needed
to show this transformation
in a fluid way they also wanted to give
animators the power to dictate all the
details of that change
such as where the transformation begins
and the speed at which it happens
before adjustments to those kinds of
details would have to go through
animation
then go to the effects team and only
then would animators get to see how it
all looked after rendering
but for luca they created a
transformation rig so animators could
fine-tune the different aspects of the
change
one by one and see the result right
there in front of them
that way they could perfectly time the
transition from the layers of changes in
the human skin to the flipping scales
and octopus spots in the sea monster
skin
this was a new way to streamline the
whole production process
and put more artistic control in the
hands of animators
after all pixar views technology first
and foremost as a storytelling tool
whether creating a new kind of light to
better convey a character's emotions or
rethinking cloud models to give
audiences
a stronger sense of place pixar's
technical innovations have
always served its stories first and
that's the key to the studio's record of
creating both
groundbreaking innovations and beloved
movies
[Music]
you